دعوني انوه الى ما نقلته او ما نقله موقع
اكسيوس الامريكي اذا مقتل خمسه اسرائيليين
في هذه العمليه التي وقعت في
منطقه النبي يعقوب شمالي القدس
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا مراسلتنا نجوان السمري للمزيد
من التفاصيل نجوى
قبل قليل عمليه اطلاق النار
في القدس
المحتله الان اعلنت مصادر تركيا همم
عمليه وهناك اصابات اخرى وصفت بعضها في
خطيره اذا خمس خمسه خمسه قتل في عمليات
اطلاق نار
منطقه
الذي يعقوب شمال المحتله وقعت قبل قليل
عند كنيس همم يهودي في هذا في هذه
المستوطنه
حسب همم مصادر اثرائيه ايضا فانه تم
ملاحقه منفذ
العمليه الذي قام باطلاق النار بالسياره
وايه تم اطلاق النار عليه
وتحديده هناك قوات كبيره من السلطه
الاسرائيليه
مقتله منفذ العمليه
نعم اذا كما هو متوقع عندما يتم الاعلان
عن تحديد المنفذ عاده يكون قد اطلقوا
نيران عليه
وقتلوه ولكن هناك هو كبير من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تنتشر في المنطقه وتحاول همم
اجراء عمليات بحث وطنشيط للبحث عن اي همم
طالعين اخرين الشرطه في هذه العمليه
قوات كبيره من الشرطه تنتشر في محيط هذا
الهيئه الشيطان وايضا في منطقه القدس
المحتله همم في عمليات بحث وتمشيط عن همم
اخرين قد يكون لهم اي علاقه في تنفيذ هذه
العمليه وقعت قبل قليل عمليه اطلاق من
مركبه باتجاه كنيسه يهودي في الحيه
الاستطلاني
هناك تاكيد من هيئه البث الاسرائيليه
تاكيد خبر مقتل خمسه اسرائيليين في هذه
العمليه نعم نعم المصادر الطبيه اللي جايه
كما يع
رب بناء
من المصابين الثلاثه عشر في البدايه اعلنه
عن اصابه لثلاثه عشر اسرائيلي في عمليه
الاطلاق النار الواقعه بان هناك خمسه
مصابين بحرجه وقبل قليل اعلنت مصادر طبيه
اسرائيليه
مقتل خمسه منهم
اصابتهم النار